hi there i'm rayne wilson and i'm reza
aslan do you have a purpose in life reza
jesus rain it's like we barely know each
other how can you ask me that question
sounds like we got something to talk
about
[Music]
welcome to metaphysical milkshake the
show where we go deep we get weird and
we search for the meaning of life along
the way presented by cast media and soul
pancake
[Music]
okay in all seriousness yes i guess i
have a
a purpose in life i actually i've
thought about this a lot throughout my
life you have yeah well my wife and i
have this motto that we always share
which is don't have a job have a mission
which is kind of the same thing nice
right and if you pursue a mission
eventually people will pay you for it
and you're not talking about a spanish
mission like filled with monks you're
talking yeah okay that's a i was yes i
was talking about charity
in adobe building that we live in no uh
so
same as a mission i guess maybe mission
has a more like a spiritual connotation
to it but i think it means the same
thing so when you and your wife are
talking about this what do you arrive at
well her purpose is her own thing my
purpose
i would say
is
to use stories
and storytelling
in order
to reframe
people's perceptions
of
the other
ah
okay i feel like that's and everything
that i do a lot of different things
obviously like how did your jesus book
do that
so religion is storytelling okay
religion is all about storytelling and
the story that we tend to tell about
jesus is often a story that is not
really grounded either in the reality of
who jesus was but is often a story about
exclusion
and
what i did was tell a different story
about jesus that reframed the way that
people think about him same with my book
about
muhammad
same one the tv shows that i work on
this podcast you know politics politics
is just storytelling so
to me i feel like stories are the most
powerful way of changing people's minds
if
they are the kinds of minds that can be
changed i have no interest
in
expending energy on on telling a story
to someone who has no interest in
changing but how do you know because you
might well this is our this is going to
be our our epic battle again how do you
know because you could be trying you
could be attempting and they could say
no no no no and then you never know i
don't know 20 years down the line
something could shift i don't know their
minds their hearts could open i don't
know no way but i think that's my i see
that as my purpose in life okay to use
stories
to reframe people's perceptions
of each other
as long as they're willing to have those
perceptions reframed that's great that
that was about you what's your what's
your purpose in life oh man
i literally knew you were gonna ask me
this question because it's on the piece
of paper in front of me that this is
what we're going to talk about still not
ready and i'm still not ready and
honestly i don't know man i don't know i
struggle with this this is my life's big
question i mean you know at the end of
every round we say what's your life's
big question like
um so as a spiritual person
i believe that
god
call god the universe love beauty
all powerful
presence within and beyond time and
space and molecules the biggest possible
conception of god that you can in our
feeble minds can kind of point at it's
like pointing at the moon um
but
that if i can live in harmony with the
will of the universe then i'm in my
purpose so what does that mean
i don't know i think for a long time my
greatest purpose was to play
and explore playing weird characters
that are based somewhat on myself as an
actor and purpose fulfilled
yeah but i might kick that off well but
no but honestly yeah maybe because
acting is holding less and less interest
for me and less and less
meaning it used to be what i lived for i
just lived for getting a role reading
the script how am i going to bring this
to life using all of my resources my
humor my my knowledge my life experience
my weird body and bringing that to life
and that fed my soul and now
less and less that's feeding my soul and
more and more i would say
i don't know if i would call it activism
work exactly but being engaged in the
biggest most pressing concerns of the
world is is i find the most fulfilling
so
but that's that's what i find fulfilling
so what is my purpose i i i don't know
i'm just trying to stay in the in the
not knowing and stay on the path that's
pointed generally in the right direction
and i hope that the
the breezes of divine confirmation will
push me in the right direction well boy
are you in luck okay because our guest
yeah for this week's pod is the great
sofia bush beautiful actress wonderful
person uh activist passionate about so
many different causes
and she's here
specifically to talk about purpose
how do we find purpose how do we pursue
that purpose how do we how do we
maintain our our enthusiasm for that
purpose and by the way she has an
amazing podcast called work in progress
where she explores all of these issues
and topics wait are we are we shilling
other people's podcasts can we a little
bit we can do that
it's a really nice little pokemon of
course of course we are of course we are
listening to work in progress she's
amazing in every way she's got some
incredibly fascinating things to say
about this topic of purpose and meaning
and maybe she can even help you find
yours i think she might and i think she
might push me a little bit smidging away
more from acting and more towards
purposefulnesslessness
let's find out okay
[Music]
well hello my name is sophia bush i am
not
uh related to the political bush family
although lots of people on twitter
scream at me about what an embarrassment
i must be to them because i'm such a
liberal um my dad is actually from
canada he's very nice
and
uh what should i say about myself i
don't know um we do the same thing
sometimes we play pretend we're actors i
do a lot of advocacy work around causes
i care about and
politics and as you now know i
shamelessly show anyone who will look at
them pictures of my dog yeah that's
right that's what we've been doing for
the last 10 minutes yeah let's skip over
the acting thing quite so quickly can
you tell us and the listeners a little
bit more who might not be familiar with
your work oh yeah some of your shows and
uh yes um so i worked on a show called
chicago pd for many years and i got to
play a very badass lady cop and do a lot
of stunts which was super fun
and i did a really interesting sitcom
for a minute before that called partners
for the will and grace creators which
was like a totally hair brained amazing
adventure for me because i came from
single camera work before that i did a
show called one tree hill for nine years
and have made some fun movies like a
sort of cult classic high school comedy
john tucker must die which yeah we'll
never die i think it's like one of those
that has blasted
it lives on so we have you on the show
because we're talking about purpose
about finding your purpose and living
your purpose we're really drawn to and
as we've dug into your
biography and your life story
how much you're able to do and how kind
of activated you are it's really uh
inspiring it's like you're an activist
first and then actor second you're
certainly in the last few years that's
been
so much of your energy so much of your
focus has been on on activism so what is
your purpose in life let's go right to
the beginning just do it
do you see yourself having like one
overarching purpose or several
overlapping purposes wow i'm so glad you
started with an easy question yeah
right
i do love to storytell but my career is
my work
and how lucky are all of us in this room
that we love what we do for work but my
my activism my purpose
as you asked that's who i am as a person
that that doesn't stay at the stage door
when i leave
a set and
i've been
so driven by that kind of purpose since
i was a little kid and it took me a
couple of years
into working in this industry to go oh
look at this i have this big platform
and i can actually take these
conversations that i have around the
dinner table sometimes with willing
participants and sometimes with friends
who probably feel like they're being
held hostage by um my data research um
and i can have them on this great big
platform
and and
what an amazing thing
so
i think for me
any kind of contribution i can make
toward
bending
our
society
uh my community my neighborhood my
dinner table guests a little farther
toward justice
that feels like a life's purpose to me
that's like that's like the drum beat
that never goes away that that rattles
my rib cage you know bending people
towards justice i like that yeah that
explains why you you focus on so many
different things as a person who likes
to look at the world and and who is um
sensitive
and also really
sort of my sensitivities are comforted
or inspired by
data by research because math is perfect
right two plus two is always can equal
four and that i feel like is comforting
when you're looking at something like a
humanitarian crisis i think you can you
can really get into these arenas looking
at the data looking at the science
and
i just thought how weird that people
would say pick a cause you know are you
gonna focus on cancer are you gonna
focus on kids are you gonna
because you'd never go to a doctor and
have the doctor
sit you down and say what are your
symptoms and he'd be like okay cool well
i'm the bicep guy so i'm just gonna your
bicep
looks fine
like it's not connected to anything and
then they're gonna like send you to the
lung lady that's not a thing they look
at your whole system
every part of the body is a cog in a
larger machine
and the world is literally no different
the body is the microcosm of the macro
planet right so when i started pulling
at the thread of
environmental threats which was the
thing that got me to start a beach
cleanup club when i was in elementary
school that by the way no one wanted to
come to so my mom took me to the beach
by myself on saturday she's a legend
but
you know when you look at environmental
devastation and threat what happens in
so many places that are suffering from
an environmental disaster the
subjugation of women and girls women and
girls walk for water they then drop out
of school
when you look at ways to elevate
community which often
start with investing in women and girls
and then you start to see health systems
get better you see decreases in
fundamentalism and violence
it's impossible not to understand that
gender parity is worth fighting for not
just for the girls but for the boys
because a rising tide lifts all ships so
everywhere i look
everything is connected and any cause
i've been lucky enough to work on has
informed so many other causes so
when people say
pick one i'm like that that's impossible
like i'm never i'm never going to be the
cheek lady this is fascinating so um
going back to rayne's question
you don't have several purposes you have
several causes but you have one purpose
and that is
as you i think really put it really
beautifully to sort of
bend people towards justice i wonder
where where did this purpose come from
is it something that you've always had
you said you had this this whole beach
cleanup thing when you were a kid yeah
where did that come from was there a
spark is it is it friendly canadian
parents or just how you were raised yeah
it could be just being canadian yeah
my dad is a very nice canadian person my
mom is um a lovely italian woman from
jersey
um and i grew up in southern california
and i think growing up
in
the wilds you know so many people have
this mistaken thing about la and and for
me southern california is
forests and deserts and the ocean and
and nature was such an integral part of
my childhood
i got my hands on this box set of
national geographic vhs tapes when i was
a kid there were six of them and they
came in this little brown leather sort
of rectangular case i remember those
remember those i loved those and i
watched the one on the amazon rainforest
to the point of almost madness
when i started learning in school that
the rainforests were being cut down i
was inconsolable my parents were like we
don't know what to do with this child
who is so on fire about this and also so
sad how do we help her
um and and so i don't i don't know why
it got in the way it did maybe it's
because
kids haven't been cultured to
suffer the status quo so much you know
kids often just look at
what should be well it sounds like
you you felt deeply in your heart about
you know a forest or a beach or
pollution or whatever and you couldn't
rest until you had done something so
there's
uh because i'm i'm fascinated by this
connection between
the heart and action
uh that
there was there was this motivating
impulse that was just a big
weeping
oh bleeding heart liberal but weeping
heart inside that couldn't that couldn't
rest yeah um
until you had uh taken some action
yeah for sure uh
it just always was the way that i was
and i am lucky that
my family was
supportive um
that they humored me
and i think i've also
been really fortunate as i've gotten
older to find myself in like-minded
community you know my my friends are
activists and authors and people who run
incredible non-profit organizations and
b corps and and are are creating
spaces um whether through activism or
technology or whatever to try to make
the world a better place
and you know everybody teases me my best
friend always says to me she says
there's no one who's more awkward at a
hollywood party than you and there's no
one who's happier at a conference than
you like just give me a notebook
i don't know why so but this is so true
i feel this all the time actors can be
so [ __ ] boring you sit down at a
mexican restaurant with a fellow actor
and tell me about it what did you work
on how did you get cast where did did
you hear so and so got cast into the and
it's just like who the [ __ ]
cares like i'm with you and as you meet
activists um and people out trying to
make a difference in the world they're
they're so much more interesting
this podcast is sponsored by better help
is there something interfering with your
happiness or something preventing you
from achieving your goals we all are
struggling with stuff i'm struggling
with stuff you're struggling with stuff
rain sure so betterhelp will assess your
needs and match you with your own
licensed professional therapist you can
start communicating in under 48 hours
this is not a crisis line it's not
self-help this is professional
counseling done securely online there's
a broad range of expertise available
which may not be locally available to
you in many areas the service is
available for clients worldwide you can
log into your account anytime and send a
message to your counselor you'll get
timely thoughtful responses you can
schedule weekly video or phone sessions
you won't ever have to sit in an
uncomfortable waiting room as you do in
traditional therapy better help is
committed to facilitating great
therapeutic matches so they make it easy
and free to change counselors
if needed i mean it's really important
to find the right counselor for you and
listen frankly nobody actually sits face
to face with their counselor anymore
anyway that's true right that's true
why bother do it online
you can go visit their website read all
the testimonials that are posted daily
you can find out why so many people
trust betterhelp so go to betterhelp.com
milkshake that's better h-e-l-p
and join the over 1 million people who
have taken charge of their mental health
with the help of an experienced
professional in fact so many people have
been using betterhelp that they are
recruiting additional counselors in all
50 states
special offer for metaphysical milkshake
listeners get 10 off your first month at
betterhelp.com
milkshake take care of yourself people
[Music]
does a person's purpose
need to be
either fulfilled or for that matter
fulfillable
for it to
uh actually be a thing
yeah like if someone says to me my
purpose is
cleaner beaches in the next 10 years i'm
like wow go for it dude that's awesome
if someone says to me my purpose is
world peace i'm like get the [ __ ] out of
here go like get get out of here what
are you talking about my purpose is
are you gonna kick him out of his own
podcast no let's talk about this now
does a purpose
need to be
fulfillable
for it to be
real or do you know what i mean does
anyone help me out here people i don't
think it needs to be
concretely achievable to matter
because look at the end of the day we
never really know
what we're gonna be able to do and and
we never know what's coming tomorrow
but i think that what is really
important is creating a framework
that
has achievable steps so if you say as i
do i want to work on justice which means
equality
everywhere and in any space where i can
lend
help fundraise
promote whatever anyone who's doing that
work
i'm in
now
justice
sounds kind of like world peace it's
like get the [ __ ] out of here what are
you talking about but
when you create a framework and you say
okay this is the time i can put into
this this is the time i can put into the
research these are the places that i can
show up um this is where i'm gonna lend
my voice my fiscal support my emotional
support my network whatever
i think that it matters you know the
idea of taking moon shots
there's there's some like refrigerator
magnet somewhere that says like shoot
for the moon because even if you miss
you land among the stars but like it's
true you know that's that's the idea at
places like the google x lab they're
saying let's take moon shots let's try
to do really really big things that push
society forward and
i think it's important to give yourself
permission to have a big dream but also
give yourself realistic achievable goals
that come in steps so that you have a
path to walk because i know at least for
me
before i got really clear on
how i do this
i always felt like i was trying to do my
best and never doing enough and i think
that's look that's how i think most
people feel we want to be doing more we
want to be achieving more
it's really easy to feel like you're
never going to catch up to your goal so
it's probably why years ago i was asked
to to give a piece of advice to young
women and i realized i was giving it to
myself because it's what i needed to
hear and i said
you are allowed to be both a masterpiece
and a work in progress simultaneously
and of that thank you yeah
it really it was actually something i
needed to hear because i i was reminded
that i'm allowed to be proud of exactly
where i am i'm allowed to be excited
about what's going well today and still
look at the goals because if you're just
looking at the goals your whole life
goes by
and if you're just really happy with
where you are today and and not setting
some sort of goals like what's going to
happen tomorrow that's a really good
answer yeah that's so good i have a
really good answer i i feel like on a
smaller level like in therapy i kind of
came up with like it's okay to be
flawed
i can be flawed and worthwhile at the
same time yes you know so i don't need
to be perfect to be worthwhile and
uh just because i am flawed doesn't mean
that i'm not worthwhile so going to the
data points that you like that we've got
some data points here about purpose so
there's a study in the journal of
american medical association jama which
sampled 7 000 people
in a psychological well-being evaluation
and the study's results indicated that
stronger purpose in life was associated
with decreased mortality
purposeful living
may have
health benefits
so
um
here's another one about uh the greater
good science center uc berkeley talks
about how isolation is an obstacle to
finding your purpose and people that
have a purpose have better physical and
mental health purpose is adaptive in an
evolutionary sense it helps both
individuals and the species to survive
to have a purpose but here's my question
for you so
is purpose the same as meaning
um like your purpose is kind of activism
what about what if there's someone
that their purpose is not
to plant trees or save the rainforest or
you know hug koala bears or whatever
that their purpose is the quest question
for meaning the question
to define meaning in their life a larger
to love people better to be a better
parent
um to try and be kinder or something
like that but they're not necessarily an
activist so that's a couple questions
can you have a purpose that doesn't
involve activism and
can uh and is the purpose the same as as
meaning can you have a meaning in your
life that's separate from your purpose
how are those connected
i think you can absolutely
have meaning and purpose that has
nothing to do with activism
that's my outlet and and i by no means
expect everybody to be all in on
everything but i do think we need
everybody to be all in on something
i think that striving to be a better
spouse or friend or child
or parent is incredibly meaningful and
important and and i actually think that
any
any ripple effect you can have even if
it's with one other person for more
kindness more love um more
open-mindedness that that all feels
revolutionary to me not just you know
standing at the head of a march in
washington dc i think all of it
really matters and you know
i take some of my free time
to just do things that feel meaningful
to me to be in nature and be quiet
to
um
read poetry that i really love i'm
trying to do that more
i need meaning to feel fueled
as a human
first and foremost and also as as a
human who's out here working in these
activists you're defining meaning as
something that fulfills you
and purpose is something that drives you
is that what i'm hearing oh that's a
nice way of putting it thank you
i had never thought about it that way
but i like that i i like
i like what you're saying and yeah for
me purpose is a driver
you know spirituality as rain and i have
talked about is a it's a it's a journey
it's an ongoing conversation that
between you and and the universe it's a
struggle all right i mean you have to
sort of renew it over and over again and
i would say that's true of purpose as
well i'm sure that
you've had
many many profoundly
negative experiences
experiences that have made you even
question
the purpose that you're pursuing or
whether it's even achievable or should
you even bother or maybe i'll just go do
another movie and [ __ ] this whole thing
how do you get past that how do you get
past failure how do you get past
pessimism
how do you keep your eyes focused on on
your purpose
i think that it is really important to
be grounded in
the reality of situations but to always
try our best i mean i make no excuses
for our current political leadership but
i think back to
things that i've seen happen in the sort
of political spectrum before when people
who actually seem to care about the
world were in charge
and how sometimes you have to choose
between something that's
kind of bad and something that's really
bad and those are your only two options
it's it's this flowery idea that there
will just be some perfect choice to make
every time
but i think as long as we are always
doing the next right thing as long as we
are always
really striving
to make things better for as many people
as possible i think that as long as
we're not
unjustly giving up on people
you know that
that's the road we should be attempting
to travel and when there is failure when
there are setbacks when unfair things
happen
we have to understand to your point that
those are part of life but they are not
a measure of our worth
you know we can really come together
um and support each other and and i
think we have to be careful that when we
need support we don't your earlier point
isolate and back away because it gets
really easy to find the claws that fit
our wounds if we're not doing
the work and the mental inventory and
and the care
uh
with and for ourselves that we need to
be
that's beautiful
we've done a couple episodes that has
really looked at millennials and gen z
and the
epidemic amounts of loneliness
chronic dissatisfaction anxiety
depression and it seems like purpose may
be a solution to this but
how do you know you're a college kid and
you're you you're 50 000 in debt you're
working at starbucks you're a little
lost how do you find your purpose
um how do you find the thing that may be
your salvation to
a happy fulfilled powerful life yeah i
think something that's really really
helpful for me when i'm trying to tackle
anything is whether i do it on a piece
of paper or on a white board i make two
lists i make a list of everything
that i care about
interchangeable with everything i'm
interested in if you're a murray condo
fan interchangeable with everything that
sparks joy and then i make a list of the
things that i do every day
and i do them side by side and i compare
lists
and
if the two things that line up on that
list are
um
fighting for social justice and reading
the news i'm like ah that's where i'm
aligned i think it's important to start
looking at where you're aligned i think
it's important to start also looking at
where you feel out of alignment and look
when you are
you know to your point in college and
you're
tens of thousands of dollars in debt and
you are working you know as a barista or
working at a bookstore or whatever it is
you're doing
those are things that you can't change
so
try rather than
to think about being miserable at your
part-time job try to think like i'm
hustling because i'm worth it i'm worth
the hustle i'm worth this degree and i'm
worth the two jobs and i'm worth the
whole thing
i just want to say like first of all i
hear you and i feel for you and second
of all i hope it's not totally
irritating that i'm like let me give you
some advice on how to do this but i
think that figuring out ways to reframe
your situation
and
and put that kind of like
passion fire on it like i really when
i'm overwhelmed and feel like i might
cry i'm like reframe it i'm hustling i
am on again i love her i'm like i am on
my jlo [ __ ] how you know and i and i try
to remind myself what a privilege it is
to be busting my ass
and then
when you identify areas where you're
aligned or maybe you have this thing on
your list of these are things i really
care about um service i care about the
planet is your issue the environment is
it is it women is it um you know an
education thing happening in your
community yeah but if you care about it
how do you know that you can make a
difference because
showing up always makes a difference and
the best piece of advice i've ever heard
i got it from glennon doyle now i tell
it to everybody is help the helpers
you're not supposed to be when you're
starting out you're not an expert that's
okay no one expects you to be but
we now have this thing called google
which when you we the three of us were
children didn't exist yes and it's
pretty easy we had the encyclopedia
britannica
um but so you can you can find
places in your community you can find
organizations that are doing the kind of
work that matter to you you can
volunteer one night a week you can show
up somewhere on a sunday morning
you can
go around your dorm and collect stuff
for a clothing drive you can raise money
for a food drive you can start in
whatever way you can to give back and i
promise you it will change your life it
will help you get out of isolation it
will help you feel
feel better and find your community
and when i really leaned hard
into
not trying to cram a movie that like
maybe i liked or didn't really like but
here i am working hard um when i was
working on one tree hill i used to like
hustle so hard in the summer to try to
do all the jobs that i could and there
was one summer i said you know what i'm
going to do this summer i'm just going
to go to every conference i care about
and
that was the year that changed my life
that was the year that i met my best
friends in the world who are my family
i found my people i found my place i
found my purpose by showing up to learn
from people who knew more than me
and that's really where i i got to apply
all my journalistic curiosity that has a
wonderful humility to it as well yeah
i love i love to be good advice yeah oh
yeah be in a room with people
seek out rooms filled with people who
are smarter than you and just go and
learn i mean just the idea the way you
put it i it just seems so awesome i
never thought about it this way but of
course it would never occur to you no
wonder occurred to me this idea of of um
the two lists i think is so brilliant
you know the sort of the things that are
important to you and then the things
that you do in your life anyway
and then find where there's alignment
and focus and within that alignment
rests your purpose that is
good advice
[Music]
so sophia we're gonna go to our
lightning round this is how we wrap up
every interview give us your best
instinctual response okay um to life's
deepest most probing questions
uh
describe your soul in 10 words or less
uh curious enthusiastic
vulnerable
hmm
tender
feisty that's five um
passionate
hungry
love a snack
um we have chips in the waiting room do
you yes doritos all the doritos you can
eat okay it could be ten words or less
you don't have to get those keywords i
felt good about that uh what does your
deathbed look like
uh hopefully
uh close to a hundred surrounded by
family and with a dog because that's why
i'll have lived too close to 100 why you
made it to 100 exactly oh how about 100
dogs i look i'm not mad at it i might
become the i might just like move to new
mexico get a ranch and have 80 dogs when
i'm retired
what's one thing that you know for sure
that people are good
i know that to be true all people
i think most people
which is
something that gives me hope wait wait
wait wait people are good all people
most people most people are good you
don't know that for sure there are some
people who i who i do think really get
motivated by
nefarious
things
shall we say um
but i yeah to some people your real
answer is
most people are good mo the majority
some are really really bad are really
good at heart
and then finally what is your life's big
question
my life's big question um
god i'm just
i wonder how it's all gonna turn out
but i smile when i ask that sorry i
feel
uh
i feel like it'll be good i hope it'll
be good
sofia bush this was an invigorating
conversation invigorating is it great it
really was i feel invigorated my purpose
has been refreshed thank you truly for
your time and for being on the show it's
a great conversation really kind thanks
for having me
[Music]
um that was awesome i got to be honest
with you
i am not very easily either impressed or
activated by other people but i was both
impressed and activated
by sophia
what about you did she help you find
your purpose what do you think i don't
know about that specifically but boy a
lot of things
she said about you know learn from the
helpers
was really important for me to hear
right about now um
somehow i think maybe it's just a white
male thing like i need to be the
authority all the time and so i think it
was good to to think about that kind of
humility to
to learn and serve what about the whole
like
make two lists values and what you
already do and maybe like find
the alignment there yeah well i mean i i
i like tennis
listen no offense rainbow dash but
you're running out of time here so i
mean you're what you're saying i'm
running out you're 64. okay come on i'm
53
you're 53. you don't have that much time
left to find your purpose listen like
look
okay our producer amy sent us um
a a kind of a purpose wake-up call if
you will that's something that all of
our listeners should probably do right
okay okay this is how we're gonna do
this i want you to get out your
calculator all right i see i've got it
here on my laptop here we go we're going
to do some we're going to do some life
math life i'm going to do it with you
people do it at home can the folks at
home everyone at home can do this along
with us okay this is how this is going
to work
you're going to take
your
age okay all right
your real age not your fake age okay
um you're going to multiply it by 365
okay okay
now subtract that number from 30 000
that's you're basically your average
life expectancy right there you're gonna
get what are you gonna get
yeah
10
655. you have 10
655 days left holy [ __ ] not just to
discover your purpose but to fulfill it
uh okay so why are you still in this
podcasting booth that's that i gotta get
out there get the forget out there i
gotta get out there i gotta get to work
i on the other hand have like twelve
thousand eight hundred and forty five
lots of times plenty of time that's
plenty more time to find out you can
just have your purpose and a couple of
hobbies i mean i'm just gonna sit in the
corner and you can waste some time just
like drink a diet coke
what about you listeners what is your
purpose do the life math get out your
calculator take your age multiply it by
365. subtract that number from 30 000.
that's the difference that's how much
you've got left that's what that's all
you got left people find your purpose
what is your purpose tell us
milkshakers as you know when you rate
and review us on apple podcasts you get
to come to our show and ask us good
things happen that's right good things
happen
including getting to talk to us in
person and uh
we have someone uh who has done that uh
joining us enid from los angeles hi enid
hi
uh were you by chance named after the
city in oklahoma i wasn't but there's
also a university there so i found out
very quickly when i was applying to
colleges that there's an in oklahoma i
didn't know that yeah that was my first
uh that was my first stop in america oh
cool my family fled iran
into the
cold
open arms of enid oklahoma i don't have
any enid stories you have no init
stories at all i don't have any enid
stories okay well then i'm leaving
what brings you here enid did you have a
question for us you left a question for
us yeah i just was curious um what you
guys think about ghosts
um
my husband and i disagree i believe in
ghosts i think our last apartment had
ghosts he thinks i was just
um absent-minded losing things
um my mom had a pretty um like i think
clear run-in with um the ghost of my
grandmother so i believe fully but um he
does not at all so i was hoping maybe
you guys could help us
work it out i we look everybody's got a
ghost story right i mean i've got a
ghost story ryan you've got a ghost
story certainly i've got yeah i've got a
couple ghost stories yeah did we tell
ghost stories before reza well that that
podcast has not actually been released
yet there is a podcast uh coming up in
which we tell our own uh individual
ghost stories i will say that my
housekeeper
thinks that our garage is haunted
just the garage just the garage she came
to us and she's like mr meester
and i'm not i'm not trying to be racist
i'm really not she says meester
it's it's kind of the cutest thing she's
wonderful sylvia and she's like there's
dimonas
de monas in the garage what was the what
what did she experience she said that
the doors kept opening when she she
would close them and come back in and
they would be open kind of like sixth
sense you know with all the the
cupboards open telltale sign in it
what's your give us your like telltale
sign of a ghost
well i can tell you my mom's story
because i actually haven't had any
what i think is direct contact i think
my mom's counsel is more direct my
grandmother passed away
um my family's from puerto rico so we
were down in puerto rico for
her funeral and
um it's it was it's her mother-in-law's
my dad's mom
and um in puerto rico like the older
ladies wear these like big mumu
things they call them batas and spanish
like really big like house coats
um
and so my mom was in the kitchen and she
like spilled something on herself so she
went into her um suitcase to look for
something new and folded up very cleanly
and beautifully was one of my
grandmother's house coats like under all
of her clothes
under all of the clothes and so my mom
got instant chills she went and she
obviously didn't pack that from home
um she pulled it out she put it on she
thought it was like some kind of like
sign that she wait she put it on yeah no
no no no that's not what you do no i'm
sorry that's the part in the movie where
the audience is like no
don't put on the haunted moomoo she
thought it was like a warm gesture from
her from my grandmother being like here
wear this because which is what my
grandmother would have done like here
you can borrow this oh it's a terrible
idea and then um the same thing with the
open and so then that evening
she was up late with my aunt talking and
they together closed all the doors and
turned off all the lights and then in
the morning when she woke up my dad was
like why did you leave all the doors
open and all the lights on everything
was open and she was like nope my aunt
or your um sister and i
closed everything together so between
those two things were pretty clear that
um
the ghost was still around here's here's
the the the thing that i always come
back to in moments like this you know
what it's like do you believe in ghosts
or do you believe in this and that
i think if you believe in god as i do
you should probably be open to some
pretty absurd possibilities do you know
what i mean like it's hard to be like i
believe in god do you believe in ghosts
no that's stupid
you know are you saying that there's a
supernatural element to believing in god
i just think
that because
let me answer can i answer that my own
question yes because i think you know
when you when they have these arguments
with like atheists on messages boards
like there's no god that's superna i
don't believe in supernatural beings
like
yeah god
is supernatural he is beyond
the natural in terms of like natural
you know science like molecules outside
our window so if you're open to
uh a some kind of supernatural or supra
natural i would say because above and
beyond the natural world then you're
exactly right i'm with you 100 percent
and please let's not forget that the
that the category of what is natural is
constantly changing right sure things
that we thought were supernatural 500
years ago are natural now
and
there is absolutely no reason to think
that you know at some you know distant
time and place we won't recognize that
you know the laws of uh conservation
being as they are the you know the
notion that energy and matter are
uh irreducible and and uh eternal and so
maybe we have the ability to kind of
measure you know the presence of uh
paranormal energy and then we'll we'll
all say well it's not supernatural
anymore now it now it fits as natural
but other supernatural things i don't
believe in right but i want to know in
those ghost hunter shows they never find
the ghost and they're always like
the commercial break they're like what
is that do you hear it oh my god i'm
picking up something we'll be right back
and then you come back and like
oh
no it might have been a cat
do you still have the mumu
um i don't know she might she might
still have it at home would you call us
back wearing it
just to see what happens i don't live
they live in boston now but yeah if i
find it i will let you know i feel like
this to me is the perfect uh kind of
question to throw back to our audience
what do you guys think milkshakers do
you believe in ghosts uh yes or no and
why do you have a ghost story and the
answer is yes we all have ghost stories
i mean we do we all do uh what's your
ghost story uh find us on apple podcasts
uh you can rate and review us and write
down your ghost story tell us whether
you believe in ghosts come on on the
show maybe we'll do an entire episode on
ghosts oh i'd like that enid thank you
so much thank you enid thank you so much
it's such a pleasure and uh and uh tell
your mom that she gives us the creeps
and if you want more of life's big
questions it's easy you can find us on
social at reza aslan and rainwilson on
twitter at metamilkpodcast
on twitter and on instagram at
metaphysical milkshake let us know your
life's big questions do you believe in
ghosts we just might explore them on
future episodes
thank you again to our guest sophia bush
you can find her on her socials at
sophia bush on all the places that we
would be i've run out of the social
platforms
i literally don't know what tick tock is
yeah anyway
uh check out her podcast work in
progress wherever you listen to podcasts
amen brother thank you sophia thanks for
listening
[Music]
metaphysical milkshake is executive
produced by rayne wilson reza aslan and
colin thompson it's produced by safa
samezadeh yaz harris lane mick dimaria
himself and dj lubell cast media is the
production and distribution partner it
is edited by tyler newbold and audio
mixed by joshua harris original music is
composed by jeff tang
it was produced by amy s choi and
rebecca lehrer of the mashup americans
associate producers are jocelyn gonzalez
lindsay crowderwill sarah pellegrini
mary phillips sandy and shelby sandlin
[Music]
look at this stupid face oh oh my god
your dog looks so much like my dog
really
sophia we have the same dog oh my god
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
hey thanks for watching you guys for
more fantastic videos just like the one
that you watch please subscribe to our
youtube channel thank you